it's no secret the las vegas community
is a giving and caring community so many
of our viewers
are doing great things all around the
valley so we decided to launch
a segment to tell their stories it's
eight points of community pride
this week we beam a proud light on iraqi
war veteran
sergeant patrick parker or sergeant
push-up as he's known
for his commitment to helping children
during the pandemic
this week the sergeant did 1 000
push-ups at the three-square food bank
to raise awareness and funds for
childhood hunger
well being a veteran the one thing i
want people to understand it's not about
what you did
i served in iraq got two bronze stars
from that
but that was then what are you doing for
america today
and if we can't help the children then
who are we
wow he also wrote an anti-germ comic
workbook
and his push for hunger awareness has
already gotten over 365 thousand meals
for children across america thank you
for all your service sergeant push up
if you have a story of our basically of
our community coming together well we
want to
hear about it share it with us for more
information visit eightnewsnow.com